it makes you realize like you really use
very clinical yeah you but you really
are helpless like it was nothing I can
do
yeah there's nothing I can do about that
to stop that Kevin Hart is opening up
about his September car crash here's the
most humbling thing in the world this is
a demonstration of how good god is man
you know I'm humbled I'm blessed
the 40 year olds comedian got candid on
his Sirius XM radio show straight from
the heart detailing the process of his
recovery including the moment he got a
suppository in the hospital to help him
go to the bathroom and I'm like man like
this is this is so bad my wife in the
room this is just a bad feeling all
around for me my stomach felt like
somebody's they lit dynamite in do it in
my stomach and rang all I could do is
called Nikko Nikko on the bed sleep in
the I said babe it's happening she said
what I said everything Kevin explained
to that he went to the bathroom in a
bucket and had to be cleaned off by a
male nurse named Jose Jose grabbed the
gauls put some spongy soap on the girls
turn me around start wiping my ass he
said was okay man he said I have a
doorman for 40 years he said it's better
out here than in there man keep it
coming man the actor said he's gotten a
lot of support along the way including a
little love from Oprah Winfrey Oprah
sent me flowers that are still alive
I've been to months of some changed and
flowers in Bush that's a different type
of money when you can find a flower to
stay alive Kevin made his first public
appearance since the accident at the
2019 People's Choice Awards where he
took home the award for favorite comedy
act first and foremost man thank God
because I definitely don't have to be
here
being that I am that makes me appreciate
life even more it does choke you up the
accident left Kevin spine fractured in
three places requiring him to undergo
major surgery Kevin first broke his
silence on October 11th sending well
wishes to Jared s black the driver of
the car as well as Jared's fiance
Rebecca Brock Strommen who was also a
passenger in the car
on Thursday Rebecca shared several pics
from the crash and the hospital
alongside a lengthy post which read in
part quote grateful and blessed
September 1st 2019 was the scariest day
of my life
God was definitely watching over us that
night and protecting us thank you Lord
for wrapping your loving arms around us
in our time of need